哈喽大家好
今天我们要来聊一个很酷的主题
我们要深入猜解一位知名交易员
巨人杰
他的核心心法
我先讲哦
今天这一集
你不会学到什么神奇的技术指标
但是他有很有可能会完完全全
颠覆你对交易的根本看法
为什么这么说
因为对一个专业的交易员来说
成功的关键
从来就不是去预测市场
而是一种
你可能
从来都没想过的思维模式
好
我们直接切入正题
你先问问你自己
很诚实的问哦
你做交易是为了什么
是为了证明自己看对了吗
是为了享受那种
你知道的
我就知道会涨
的那种快感吗
还是说你其实是为了
稳定地获利
这两件事
听起来好像差不多
但跟你说实际上根本是天差地远
这就是专业交易员跟业余玩家最大的分水岭
你到底是把交易当成一个满足自尊心的游戏
还是把它当成一门非常严谨的生意在经营
好那这就带我们来到第一个重点
所谓的算命师陷阱
你看哦
有太多太多人
把交易当成一颗
可以预测未来的水晶球
每天都在那边猜呀猜
猜市场下一步要往哪走
但老实说
这一条路根本就是一条死胡同
这句话可以说是巨人姐
她整个交易哲学的基石
她说她不是市场的预言家
她做的是什么
是几率的精算师
所以重点从来就不是猜对方向
而是在于去计算
这笔交易如果我一直做下去
长期来看它到底划不划算
诶 那什么是期望值
听起来好像很学术
但其实很简单
简单来说就是
你把所有可能发生的结果
都乘上它发生的几率
然后全部加起来放到交易里面意思就是如果同一笔交易你重复做个1百次一千次平均下来你每一次出手大概可以赚多少钱
或赔多少钱
你看
这完全是一个数学概念
它把你的个人情绪
全部都排除在外了
好
所以当我们懂了期望值之后
就可以进到第二个核心思维咯
那就是
要像庄家一样思考
你必须从一个
每天都希望好运降临的赌客
转变成那个设计游戏规则
掌握数学优势的赌场老板
你看这张图
就把这两者的差别
讲得非常非常清楚
左边是散户
是赌客
他们在干嘛
他们在猜结果
他们追求很高的胜率
他们很容易被情绪影响
那右边呢
右边是庄家
也就是专业的交易者
他们做的是计算长期的赔率
他们专注的是高的赚赔比
而且他们会严格遵守自己的一套流程
他们心里非常清楚
自己根本不需要每一次都赚赔
哇
这句话就更精辟了
为什么专业人士不追求胜率
你想想看
因为胜率是有极限的嘛
你再怎么厉害
也不可能达到百分之百
可是赚赔比
也就是我们常说的风险报酬比
理论上是没有上限的
这代表什么
代表你可以赔五次小钱
但只要让你抓到一次大的
一次就可以把前面全部赚回来
甚至还多赚
我们举个例子好了
比如说一个五比一的赚赔比
这意思就是
你冒着赔一块钱的风险
去拼一个赚五块钱的机会
在这种策略底下
就算你的胜率低到只有六分之一
就算你连续赔了五次
只要第六次你做对了
那一次就把前面所有的亏损都打平了
各位
这个就是庄家的数学优势
好
所以心态我们建立好了
那具体到底该怎么做呢
接下来
我们就来看看专业交易员的战术手册
巨人节把它归纳成三大核心逻辑
第一个逻辑
资讯永远优先于图表
很多人得搞臭了
他们朝爱研究K线图啊各种形态啊但问题是,图表进入的永远都只是已经发现过的事就像这句话说的K线图它就只是价格走势的一个记录而已
它是一个落后指标
真正驱动市场的是背后的资讯
还有因为这些资讯所引发的供需关系
你想想看
是不是因为一则新闻
一份财报或某个突发事件
才导致买卖双方的力量失衡
然后价格才会动
所以图表只是结果
它不是原因
好 再来是第二个逻辑
我觉得这一招超级实用
叫做试单的艺术
意思就是说
当你对市场有一个看法的时候
千万不要一开始
就把你全部的资金都压上去
它的流程是这样子的
第一步 测试
用一个非常小的部位先进场探探路
第二步验证
看看市场的反应
是不是跟你想的剧本一样
第三步加码
如果市场真的证明你的想法是对的
这个时候才开始把部位放大
但最关键的是什么
是万一市场的走势不如预期
你必须要毫不犹豫的执行第四步离场
把这个小部位砍掉
直接任赔出场
这个观念真的超重要
你因为适当而产生的小亏损
拜托
你千万不要把它看成是失败
或者是我又做错了
你应该把它当成什么
当成是为了取得市场资讯
必须付出的成本
就像你做生意
要有进货成本一样
这个就是你教育事业的一部分
好
那这就带到我们的第三个逻辑了
聪明的部位控管
这也是把你前面所有的想法
真正转化成利润的
最关键的一个环节
这里有几个关键原则
你一定要记住
首先
大的部位是钻来的
不是你一开始就压下去的
你必须要透过试单
证明你的逻辑是对的
才值得你把部位放大
再来你要记住市场根本不在乎你买了多少所以千万不要因为自己部位很大就开始一厢情愿最后也是最重要的一点
就是因为你一开始的部位很小
所以当你看错的时候
你才能够毫无压力的
非常轻松地退场
好终于我们来到最后
也是最困难
但同时也最重要的一个部分了
驾驭你自己的心智
因为说真的
就算你把前面所有的策略都搞懂了
但如果你心里这关过不去
那一切都只是空谈
你账面上的赚赔
你的持仓成本
你的平均价格
你知道吗
这些数字其实都在对你说谎
它们会让你产生一种执着
让你做出非常不理性的决策
一个专业的交易员
他看的永远是当下的市场状况
而不是他自己账户里的那些数字
这里有一个听起来好像很矛盾
但其实非常深刻的心理法则
首先赔钱的感觉必须要是痛苦的
这种痛不是为了要让你很沮丧
不是
是为了让你对市场永远抱持着一颗敬畏的心
让你不敢随便乱冒险
但是与此同时
当你在赚钱的时候
你又必须要保持绝多的冷静
甚至要感觉到有点麻木
为什么
因为兴奋跟贪婪
就像是毒药一样
它会让你失去判断力
让你做出很愚蠢的决定
只要保持冷静
你才有可能在这个市场里面
活得够久
所以
简单来说
你就是要练习
把兴奋感当成是毒药一样去避开它
然后把亏损带来的痛感
当成是你最好的老师
这个就是一个专业交易员
需要修炼的情绪纪律
好
那今天的分享差不多就到这边
最后我想留一个问题给你思考一下
在你下一次要进场交易的时候
你愿意支付多少的资讯成本
来验证你自己的想法呢
这个问题的答案
我想或许就会是你改变交易生涯的一个开始
谢谢